TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hi, my
name is Timothy Jordan.
I'm a developer
advocate here at Google,
and I'd like to give you a quick
introduction to Android Wear.
Android Wear is a set of
APIs that extends the Android
platform to a new
generation of wearables.
Rich notifications can
appear on the wearable,
with no modification to
the existing Android app.
The developer can add just
a few more lines of code
to extend the
wearable experience
or go even deeper, by building
an app just for the wearable.
Before we dive into the
details of the platform,
let's take a step back.
What's wrong with this picture?
We spent some time looking
at technology usage
and thought deeply
about the ways
to help you stay more
connected to the digital world.
But also more engaged with
what's happening around you.
Android Wear looks
to address this
by showing you useful
information the moment you
need it, and just in a glance.
Let's look at that in
a more technical way.
This is your day
with your phone.
Notice the length
of time it takes
to pull out your phone
from your pocket,
unlock it, navigate to what you
want, and then engage with it.
There's a hefty time
and attention cost,
even for interactions that
should only require a moment.
This is the same set of
interactions on a wearable.
Notice the reduced
overhead per interaction.
Now this is what we mean by
more present in the real world,
and yet more connected
to the virtual world.
What does this mean
for your development?
Well, to start with,
and this is important,
it's a fundamentally different
user interaction model.
And you can tell just by
looking at this device.
It's a fundamentally
different device
from other mobile devices.
To really nail the
user experience,
you've got to
rethink it a little.
When considering which
features of your service
you'd like to make
available on the wrist,
consider this question.
What couldn't we do on
the phone that we can now
do on the wrist?
What now becomes
possible with the user?
And then focus on that.
Also, you've got to try it.
It may sound silly, but once
you get that emulator up
and running, stand
up at your desk
and pretend you're
walking between meetings
or across the street.
Something to get yourself
in the situation,
so you know what it feels like
to use the service on the go.
Here's an example
of what we mean
by a very basic but
essential difference.
This is the app
experience on your phone.
Now we've trained users to
collect these shiny objects,
and then search
for them when they
want to do something,
which works OK on a phone.
But if we put these same shiny
objects on a wearable, well,
it just doesn't make sense.
It would be the same
time consuming paradigm,
but on a device
intended to reduce
those parts of the interaction.
It just doesn't make sense.
How do we get outside
of this paradigm?
How do we get past
this grid of icons?
This is the Android
Wear interface.
It's simple, glanceable, and
built around microinteractions.
The interface is divided
into two primary behaviors.
The user can talk
to the wearable.
You can think of
these as actions.
The user might say, OK Google,
and then any voice command
is available to them.
The wearable can
talk to the user.
Now think of this
as a context stream.
It's sort of like
enhanced notifications
that matter to the
user right now,
because it's the
right time or place.
OK.
Let's talk about developing
with Android Wear.
First, notifications.
The notifications on
your phone can also
be displayed on the wearable.
And to get this done you
don't have to do anything.
It just works out of the box.
Also, notifications that buzz or
sound on the companion device,
such as your phone, will
also buzz on the wearable.
Enhanced notifications will
also show up on the wearable.
And again, to get
this done you still
don't have to do anything.
It also already
works out of the box.
There are a few things that you
can do with your notifications,
specifically on the wearable.
And these do require
a few lines of code.
Stacks allow you to bundle
multiple notifications
together.
Think inbox style notifications.
Pages.
They give you the ability to
show more than one glanceable
screen of information to the
user for a single notification.
And yes, Pages can be
combined with Stacks.
Replies.
They allow you to add
actions to notifications
that the user can
control with their voice,
via open-ended text input
or through pre-defined text
responses.
If you want to have code
running on the wearable,
you're going to have
to build an app.
The SDK for apps
isn't available yet.
But here's a few
notes to get you
started thinking about them.
You can create custom card
layouts and run activities
directly on wearables.
You can send data and
actions between the phone
and a wearable with
data replication
APIs and remote procedure calls.
You can gather sensor data
and display it in a real-time
on Android wearables.
And you can register
your app to handle
Voice Actions, like OK
Google, take a note.
And that's the
Android Wear platform.
Please check out more detail
on our excellent documentation,
developer.android.com/wear.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next time.